let's begin you get this probability
density function I think you're pretty
happy with that idea that you've got
some function in here in a particular
domain we need to restrict the domain
otherwise when you you know expand the
domain maybe it goes negative
maybe you if you were to integrate will
be more than 1 or less than 1 or
whatever so we've got this restriction
and then everywhere else zero don't
worry about it basically okay so we want
to use all of that together and combine
that with like a probability of some
kind okay now I think it would actually
be helpful and I'm sorry I'm gonna I'm
gonna cheat slightly but you can I will
let you benefit from my cheating uh-huh
we're gonna get a picture of this very
roughly okay because I think it will
help to understand what's happening now
before I start to put this into desmos
to see what it looks like um what can
you tell me about this function what do
you think it would look like kind of
function is it's a parabola
yeah perfect it's you have that x
squared there right and then you're like
oh then there's all this other stuff
like it's a parabola I think you can
probably tell me is it is it facing
downwards or is the facing upwards it is
facing upwards cuz you're like there's
no negatives there well okay so then it
starts to get me blurry right because
you're like oh with a straight line if Y
if I had well no no I don't because it I
don't think it's a bad place your brain
to go like steepness and there so with
straight lines right we have this um we
have this standard format right and we
can say oh as soon as you look at this
thing that tells you the gradient and a
straight line always has the same
gradient unlike a parabola which is kind
of like sometimes there's another fourth
and then you know these are the
intercept so you can read those things
off very easily yeah this this is yeah
if you wanted to find that intercept
you'd be like oh it's it's four times
three over 13 area so you're getting the
idea but I actually want to look at what
this is like and once we've got a shape
for this you're welcome to just do a
rough sketch for yourself so that you
you have that to refer to okay three
over 13 and then what do we got in there
x squared plus four wasn't it okay so
here
is our parabola and importantly just
like in the original question we're not
interested in the entire parabola we're
interested only in a particular domain
so I look over there at the domain
restriction and I don't know if you've
seen me do this enough on desmos and
when you're filming with desmos if you
go to this other keyboard here and this
is the alphabet keyboard there is right
down the bottom there are these curly
braces which you can see on the top and
they allow you to specify the domain so
I want it's very handy 0 is less than X
which is less than 1 correct I mean I
think that's just the what desmos is
interpreting is domain anyway you're
like oh who's that hit right in fact
even though it's a parabola it's such a
small pot or a parabola it almost looks
like a straight line but you can see the
curve there okay alright so that's good
and not that we necessarily need it but
we can just prove to ourselves that this
is a probability density function I
don't know if you knew you could do this
too but des mots will integrate if you
like so what I'm gonna do is yeah good
so let's just um show you how that works
oh good it's right it's very handy so
I'm gonna call this f of X because the
question does f of X equals that and I'm
gonna integrate now one of my boundaries
again it's zero and one so I'm gonna go
from naught to one because I'm lazy I'm
not gonna write that whole function
again I'm just gonna call it f of X and
then I of course I have to say am i
integrating with respect to like what
letter
there's only X's here so I'll say D X
and lo and behold it's one which which
it had better be right okay so now we're
then asked ya if we were asked to prove
that this was a probability density
function we need to show number one
that's always about zero and number two
that it integrates to 1 so can't you
just logically deduce that if you just
if you see that x squared plus any
constant you can tell that if there's a
zero there it's gonna zero out the only
thing you really have
is the one correct that's right so yes
so you'd have to substitute one in to
this like even though you can it sure I
mean if you're asked to prove something
such as prove that this is a Provo
density function test you know test
you'd yeah you and but I mean even even
so like mathematical you take to be
rigorous it's like I can't just say it
looks like it's kind of funny you know
as you can imagine you know these days
we wouldn't labor the point over like
for example if you had a probability
right and if it was a discrete
probability situation so it's like I'm
counting things up so if I had an answer
like oh I don't know it was four over
twelve right
we would not bad an island and say yeah
that's that's fine you don't need to
simplify that to any easier fraction you
don't have to write that that's 1 over 3
that's fine
and so the further you go into math the
more that you treat all the previous
stuff is like yeah that's fine
we get it don't worry about it and so at
a certain point like sometimes you're in
in mathematical papers the phrases
appear like by inspection which is
basically this by saying I looked at it
and I'm pretty sure it's fine yeah yeah
it's a bit bit of hand waving you know
because it's sufficiently simple we're
not worried about it like deduction yeah
yeah yeah okay so anyway that was all on
the side we're now trying to think about
how do I use this probability density
function to work out this probability
okay now I I can see that that is X is
less than 0.75 so if I were to put this
back onto here yeah so I've got x equals
0.75 which is unsurprisingly it's there
at 3/4 right so because I want less than
or equal to that I want everything over
to the left correct so what I really
want it's going to look like this
where's my f of X which part I haven't
done anything like any interaction okay
we will integrate in a second we will
integrate I just wanted to make sure we
know we're calculating yeah
so I want this that's the area under the
curve we know that's the total
which is one but I actually only want it
for this specific domain 4x is less than
0.75 okay now you can see here right
because the function itself stops at
zero that's my left boundary this purple
area now right it's like Oh start at
zero go all the way up to some 0.75 is
that okay so now I've got a picture for
this this way
thank you maybe I'll just leave the
picture here on the side because I'm
because I can that'll be alright so this
probability here X is now this parts
fine and I think you were even able to
form the integral properly as well right
it's from naught check that your
workings okay there there's the there's
a naught there your point seven five at
the top and then here comes the function
so 313 x squared plus 4 we don't expect
X so far so good
yeah now at this point I think did you
already start to integrate from this
point or do you do some factorizing and
all that what did you do next from this
line I think it's a good move because
really it's just kind of in the way so I
can have a couple of guesses who might
have given a suggestion like that it's
easier to work with in this way I can
just focus on the tones at rhythm hello
that's right in Thirteen's not going to
go anywhere so at this point again
you're fine because you got 2x cubed on
3 but I think your brain was like oh
cool I've got this canceling that can
happen so you started to do this next
bit at the same time remember this I can
see some of its like scratched out in
here right so let's let's not get
carried away to that step yet because I
haven't even finished integrating this
point right yeah so that part yeah it's
just kind of I think you'll like I'm
gonna multiply by 3 anyway so I'll just
get rid of this over 3 it'll cancel
right it's fine I mean it's a very easy
mistake to make
now I hope you can see we've integrate
at this point so the x squared turns
into X cubed on 3 the 4 turn into 4x but
there's the big brackets around it 3
over 13 applies to and
everything on the inside right so that's
why I'm not you know jumping in and
doing any case that make sense yeah okay
so far so good so that's three other 13
I'm still gonna leave it at the front
yes still because um I don't really gain
all that much by multiplying the three
and because you know I if you really
want I could but I don't think it's
going to make things instrumentally
better so for example if I multiply that
by three this also gets multiplied by
three like so I mean I guess we have
gotten rid of on so if I multiply the
whole fraction this is gonna be divided
by thirteen and this is gonna be divided
by thirteen now I'm dividing by thirteen
twice rather than once you can do it
okay well let's let's see what happens
next right so I've got my one over
thirteen at the front let's see if we
interesting okay let's let's see what we
go to you from you so I've got to
evaluate at my top boundary and then
subtract from my lower boundary well as
you've already pointed out when your
lower boundary zero and you've got these
X terms in here you know that's gonna
cancel out it's going to come out in the
wash so I'm gonna get 0.75 cubed twelve
lots of 0.75 and that's the upper
boundary then I subtract the lower
boundary which we already established as
a zero yeah yeah so at this point I'm
gonna you have your calculator only I've
got one over here well let's see let's
see if we match up you have the
calculation already but it's probably
wiped off yeah it's already disappeared
so um I mean that's yeah what do we got
here I can already tell I mean that's
three sorts that 2764 plus I'm just
doing this to see if I can beat you -
yeah twelve times three quarters that's
a nine oh come on come on you can get
this guy it's gonna be gross I mean look
at those now it's fine that's okay
I am definitely you actually I've got a
calculator here don't know why I got a
bad calculator right no no that's one
over 13 and then I've got 27 on 64 lost
9 how do we go I'm getting miss arts are
seven four seven five nine six dot dot
dot
[Music]